[Music]
Olympics start smugly yeah
can't believe it really crept up on us
hey a little fun fact about the Olympics
did you hear this is actually historic
fact thanks cuz it's all I got
in ancient Greece did you know that all
Olympic athletes competed in the nude
and to honor that tradition that's how I
plan on watching the Olympics
this is popcorn by the way let's be
clear on that just you really should put
a towel down thank you Andy thank you
yeah the the London Olympics start
tomorrow night and yeah this is a little
interesting thing the games don't even
start for another 24 hours but Greece is
already 14 gold medals in debt they just
have a gift for this kind of thing and
they invented the whole deal no that's
why they're slacking yeah
this year's little a something you
should know this year's Olympics will be
replacing the women's beach volleyball
bikinis with uniforms that are less
revealing that's true yeah the stricter
dress code was made to appease the
conservative nation of buzz killest and
fun people there the cast of Modern
Family you may have heard about this
story
it's been in the news the cast of Modern
Family had delayed production for the
new season due to a contract dispute
yeah I think I speak on behalf of men
everywhere when I say give Sofia Vergara
whatever she wants
[Applause]
[Music]
interesting story in the news a recent
study shows that smoking marijuana can
help eliminate diarrhea that's true
the finding was called significant by
doctors and a win win by Taco Bell
[Music]
I'm so proud of that joke